ich konnte das hat heute die gene zu
kinos und ländern gehen uns diese starke
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen folge minecraft galaxy
zusammen mit hallo meine freunde ich
gehe direkt auf dem server
ich habe eine sache schon mal zu
erledigen relativ kleinen sache ich werd
mir diese folgen hier christel bauen
sagt dir was luca ja genau habe ich
einmal kurz erklären aber du weißt schon
was ist ne ich weiß nicht was es ist
das ich wirklich glaube schon der name
sagt dass oder das ist ein kristall mit
dem du dich halten kannst hey ich
schlecht ja das ganze im pvp oder so
schnell aufstellen und das kostet 4
ändert werden und einen diamanten und
ist wirklich ziemlich stark also das ist
relativ nützlich das teil also ein
ziemlich coole sache ansonsten wollten
wir noch dem luca so ein bisschen die
energie näher bringen ich habe hier
christian lais und johannes ist so der
plan also du brauchst ein paar sachen
deutschland du brauchst als grundlage
erstmal lara fabrikate und mathematik
deinem hatte ich noch mal ganz kurz
meine minions hier also max und ich nie
mehr zwei folgen zusammen auf die
kombinieren tag später als bei max an
alle die sich jetzt erst mal gewundert
weil ich ja alles vorproduzieren das
hier dann alles ein bisschen blöd plan
muss deshalb am main zuschauer auf jeden
fall guck doch mal morgen oder doch
morgen wird dann wahrscheinlich kommen
lukas dich dann und sie auf jeden fall
weil er ist auch super süß
ich bin total dieses gucken wir auch
alle nicht bei irgendeinem kreft sondern
einfach weil die gucken sich nur die
fans kümmern
also du bist du wohnst er neben mir nach
ich will mir ja klar max peer knauer
wirklich so mit nachnamen
tschuldigung so was diesmal jenson also
du brauchst in war ich glaube ist ein
leid das gerne mal den leuten hat er mir
zumindest auch freiwillig gehen und dass
ich geklaut haben soll
max ich habe nichts geklaut
also ich glaube das hat auf ihr kommen
wir jetzt mal crossbase jedoch auch was
das hat das ist doch gar nicht mehr
dabei hatte ich mich da habe ich mich
aber auch noch gefragt hat er da schon
öffentlich gemacht ich hab noch so lösen
sind blut eimer aus der hütte dabei
interessant klingt ein bisschen platt
ich bin jetzt bei dir wo bist du
ich komme so peters also hat heute die
gene zu groß und dünn und space
ich habe heute sturm war für schon mal
kräftig geklatscht alter wir haben
bisschen ehrlich gegeneinander gefaltet
20 hingeschickt hallo fledermaus
direkten slime jung wir brauchen uns
leihen wollte ehrlich sowie die boxen ja
direkt direkt direkt hinein stark also
wir brauchen wirklich ist dass wir die
style für dich kräften können also ist
jedoch dass er dabei deswegen kann er
unterwegs sagen das ist jetzt quasi
freis territorium hier das stimmt ja
genau hier kann die hinterlassene ich
hab zwei stück perfekt map nicht mehr
braucht man nicht so was brauchen wir
noch mal schauen was ein holz hat spyder
nur was hat er denn noch alles ins gelbe
trikot
doch nicht nur playsport luca dotti 0 1
das ist gut so die rolle wir bräuchten
tatsächlich place lakers hatte das wäre
perfekt wenn wir jetzt noch blaze zu
retten was glaubst du wie hefty
rafsanjani ja klar aber das ist halt
weit von jedes käppner nehmen das portal
ist man in einen hersteller entweder
total uncool ist es stimmt ja ich gehe
mal kurz drüber schauen wir brauchen auf
jeden fall ein bisschen in war für dich
du kannst schon mal anfangen mit
mach mal den casting noch mal mächtig
deine maus sucht das ding war das super
light assist carpenters blog karten
taste sind so dinge die man also man es
gibt dieses teilte heißt das noch
irgendwie so caritas hemmer oder sowas
und damit kann man so einige blöcke
einfach komplett modifizieren das ist
halt echt cool wenn man so aufbauen
steht so macht zum beispiel nichts
anderes sein ganzes leben lang bei mir
ist das so bauen könntest du super für
begeistert wie vielleicht einmal im
aussiehst nicht so 100 rom eine sache
irgendwann entdecke ich das für mich
draußen regnet's plattform romantisch
junge heute war in köln so ein mega
heftiges unwetter
ich hab das nicht meine mutter mit mir
sogar zum glück siehst du nach hamburg
und nicht nach köln kölner sind
dauerhaft ein unwetter läuft muss meine
ganzen scheiß kisten ihr sortieren also
was meinst du was ich mir machen
bräuchte ist auf jeden fall vielleicht
fordert such mal nach mac matic wie
magma magnetic deinem auf das ding weg
merzig hat kein in la noire okay da ist
er braucht man in was für eine
jetzt sollen weikert hier hatte ich habe
meine arbeit heften cloud gehabt was ist
nicht auf irgendwelche ärzte ich weiß
nicht genau wie man das zusammen kräfte
so engel
so wie macht man mit viel spaß
moment
ferres und einer muss man einfach
zusammen machen und das ist echt easy
ich suche ein bisschen vettels paris
paris
wie viel soll für die hohen zehn stück
la ferres ich habe 20 jahres feierlich
und iron einfach zusammen oder wie
pulver reisen müsste das so bräuchte ich
jetzt natürlich noch planespotter ich
mal ganz schnell die hölle gehen so ich
mache mein leben für dich riskieren
etwas verlegen du bist unser pv peking
gemacht dass ich hab' ich weiß nicht ich
habe jetzt nicht meine meine lava schutz
rüstung an aber nicht oder wie soll ich
das denn wir bieten das hat sich mit dem
pulver reiser packst du einfach dass
ingrid rein das geschmolzene oder noch
besser das ohr weil aus dem orbit das
doppelte das so echt wie vor allem läuft
das zeug so schnell durch ne das ist du
hast aber noch was drin
ich bin einfach aus ihren hinterausgang
spiel halten ok jetzt was packe ich da
jetzt rein nicht packt in das linke was
in linx packst du das rheinwasser
spencer ja ich habe ferres und in winter
park einfach veranlasst dass komplett
durch durch reiben und dann packst du
das einen rein und dann kannst du es im
smelter zusammentun
okay wir fangen wir fangen schon mal an
fertig auf jeden fall so ist wäre eine
krasse sache wenn wir das jetzt in zwei
folgen dem fliegen ich bezweifle auch
dass das so superschnell paris drin wie
viel davon ca von paris falls man muss
mal gucken und diesem pulver teilen ich
muss mal kommen hier fertigt eine frau
brauchst du 123 schon mal einen
mückenstich unter deiner sei der
rezession elf stück braucht
was moment ja klar russell 20 habe ich
perfekte wieder schmelzen
und ich habe jetzt ein stück pool
bereits und jetzt auch noch erfahren
ich habe allerdings gratis im netz
ich war jetzt nicht wieder
zurückgekommen ich weiß nicht wo ich auf
die schnelle jetzt place oder finden
soll
es bräuchte dann nämlich auch auf jeden
fall gibt's da nicht schon irgendwo eine
höhle oder so also einer festung
ich weiß ich hab auch irgendwo gesehen
ich bin einmal megabyte geflogene eine
folge mich aber komplett durch netter
geflogen um dann herauszufinden das
direkt am spawn wo man eigentlich raus
kommt ich habe die beiden sachen elfmal
jetzt gehe ich zum um ob ich vielleicht
selbst noch irgendwas wörter und packt
einfach nehmen dann daran hinderten
einfach nebeneinander und dann kommt es
raus eigentlich effect 2 preis ferres
metal alter was ist das für eine scheiße
geht nicht also muss man doch eigentlich
habe ich so eine unendliche
energiequelle dar angeschlossen brauche
ich oder vielleicht habe ich irgendwo
überspringen gesagt vielleicht luca
trinken sechs vielleicht apple reagieren
hält es geht nicht rein
ich hab keine ahnung was los ist da habe
ich auch keinen eigentlichen 89 geht er
einfach mit 60 abschlag mit einem
schwert oder so er greift wieder eine
kiste an schlag und ein bisschen fester
wird nun schwert dass mir der match
macht ich habe nun die schwelle nicht
vergraben
dies ist es der stadt gerade ja ich
krieg gar kein schaden wir geben ihr
christlicher orient gas oder sogar keine
chance
nur noch vier herzen drei herz ich habe
auch waffen wenn du den kommerz in
meißen
ich werde auf jeden fall nicht cool wenn
du mich jetzt töten würde jene angst du
so kann man eine ak holen also wir
wissen ja schon mal was der plan skipper
ich grad noch mal im kino ist auch sein
auch was hat denn hier cooles komplotts
geworden kannst du auf level 30 oder so
locker verzaubern
am breaking drei aufmarschs schwert das
ist die größte jacht breaking drei euro
wurde bei kinos hier unten wenn du
eigentlich dass du dir kasse 70
verzaubern bin komplett obendrauf
fliegst kannst du da unten rein eco hier
combustion generate luca packt in mainz
das hat nur für dich stehen lassen hat
er mir erzählt
okay ich gehe jetzt mal ein flop hallo
leute sind von irgendwem die minions wir
bräuchten von wie irgendwo blaze powder
dann wird das alles viel schneller gehen
aber es braucht halt echt ebensolchen
sword hat jetzt mit drei darf ich damit
mal angreifen
ja aber nur wenn ich den links platziert
dollar hängen ich komme hier nicht
fliegt hoch zu den dingen
wusstest du bist du dich lass mal pennen
gehn aus dem bett aber ich kann hast du
zeit ist aber hier in den theatersaal
einzig werde ich bin okay okay das sind
alles für uns extra für uns sein lassen
so schaffen wir dann nicht mehr dieser
folge war dass komisches melden da nicht
funktionieren da einmal das make up
funktioniert nicht wie gut wir können
schnell zu kuba fliegen aber die andere
sache ist die dass wir brauchen noch
magna cream aber wir können zumindest es
eine feile eigentlich noch fertig machen
diese folge dass eine teilt man braucht
zwei stück man braucht einmal lavafelder
und mate matic deine also der lagerfeld
wer hätte es gedacht kommentiert lover
und der magnetic dann auf erzeugt strom
aus lava meine medienzar mega zehn
millionen koffer bohnenkaffee bronder
hingeschmissen
war er eine waffe folge nicht ins bett
geht und nicht bereit waffen ist es so
schlimm wenn man vergisst sich zum affen
das waren jetzt galt ebenfalls wieder
kurz warten jetzt einfach mal so eine
neue kiste ich halte ich jetzt so viel
kommerz eine sachen klima vielleicht
noch in diese folge das werfe schon mal
eine gute sache heißt nächste öfter
waffeln bitte nächste daraufhin heute
habe ich schon zweimal eine sturm war
für kirchenkreis wo bist du bist du bist
du komm eines bahnhofs hoffentlich passt
noch nie in der anderen stadt rastan
wird hier seine premiere
diese muss schüler viel zu viel erlebt
ist so cool bleiben kurz stehen ich
möchte mit dem schwer die angreifen
wie viel schaden hat er das gemacht
alter dieser hier crystal ist so kenne
ich platzieren
hey mann christian abt komm wir gehen
hier durch durch das portal ihren ist
dabei klar selbst kommt und dann durchs
portal und jetzt sind wir erstmal in
anderen stadt gegen arbeiter her da ist
case ich sehe dich nicht du bist die
kleine verdammte pflicht sich nicht per
du siehst ja wahrscheinlich direkt in
der luft ne danke gefahr da oben so eine
geile luft basis ach so heißt sie nicht
so die geile basis nicht luft war das
aber so wie es gerade cool redstone
vereines so wo ist das ding was du
brauchst induction smelter hier guck da
packte jetzt die dinger rein in das
wetter jetzt noch mal sagen können das
jetzt mitnehmen soll
quatsch das machen wir in der nächsten
folge
er ist wir haben 40 minuten kann man
langsam zum ende kommen ja vor allem ihr
mit dem hochland ist ja nicht mehr weiß
auch wer schon mal relativ spannende
folge eigentlich erlebt jedes wie
sind im pdf geplündert wir waren luca
war das erst mal in der anderen stadt
wir haben bisschen gekämpft und so alles
was eine gute folge eigentlich braucht
oder und wir sind in der nächsten folge
dann am start mit hoffentlich dem in
warin gott ja und dann werden wir uns
darum dann ein wenig kümmern
dann würde ich sagen wenn es euch
gefallen hat lassen bewertung da wir
übermorgen wieder bei mir bei max
wahrscheinlich habt ihr die folge schon
längst gesehen